you say you're going to sing monkey
wrench I'm not singing on that one
anyway no no this is this is how we warm
up the vocals and what does it mean by
the way we were wondering that the other
monkey wrench you don't want to be your
monkey ring don't want to be a monkey
wrench means I don't want to be the
person that puts the cog in your wheel I
don't want to be the person that slows
you down
am i right was just about a girl just
about a dysfunctional relationship this
was your relationship yes my
dysfunctional really was a woman well
we're just about the guy from Nirvana
Kurt Cobain this is about a personal
love relation well there's a personal
love relationship and what did she came
to you and said you're giving her
problems and you said okay final
relationships not working out and you
don't want to torture either person and
all right let's let's listen to monkey
wrench because now we know what this is
about this is the whole band doing it
acoustically
[Music]
what it was done with innocence it is
filled with Tommy
martien
Nasir Reza
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
some ground
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sheesh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful beautiful Thanks